hi I'm Cornelius Willis with the Google
cloud platform team and I'm so excited
today because we get to talk to two
eminent technologists at Google first we
have Andrew Fikes who is a distinguished
software engineer at Google who is
working on BigTable and also the spanner
project which we've published in papers
about and then Amin Vedad who is a
Google fellow and the technical lead for
networking and we brought these two
folks together because the relationship
between the services we provide on
Google cloud platform and the
capabilities the underlying
infrastructure are really what define
Google cloud platform as a whole you
can't really look at any of these things
separately and understand really how
they come together and provide something
truly extraordinary some questions so I
mean you've said in public talks
computing is like crossroads and that
networking is going to define what
computing is in the future so why is
that yeah that's a great question I
think it really is an exciting time to
be thinking about the future of
computing we've been to some extent
spoiled in computer science for many
many decades where we would get
basically free performance improvements
every 18 months or so if you wanted your
software to run faster all you have to
do is wait for the latest greatest
processors to come available upgrade
your hardware and magically your
software run quick runs faster for the
last few years this has changed as we've
now not been able to make individual
processors faster but we've delivered
more of them so the programming model
has had to change and the network is
really the key enabler for bringing more
and more servers together to work on
bigger and bigger problems so in other
words if I look at what we do at Google
we're bringing together hundreds
oftentimes thousands of servers together
on individual computations and it is the
network that allows us to treat these
hundreds or thousands of servers as one
unit of computation I've heard you say
that it's important to have balance
between the different parts of the
infrastructure and you have to feed the
processors if you have all that
processing capacity you have to make
sure that there's the network
connectivity
give it given data to work on that's
right and so one way to look at this is
that servers need data to compute on
just doing a computation without any
data is not very interesting and at
Google and I think that's virtually any
place that's interesting the data is not
local to a server it's not that there's
no way that you're going to have the
data that you need local to you so any
data that you're going to compute on is
living across the network somewhere and
that's why it's so great to be working
closely with folks like Andrew because
the networking is about storage and I
think storage works very closely with
networking so if you look at a processor
that can do billions and billions of
operations every second how do you make
sure that you feed it data they keep
going at that rate right otherwise it's
stalled waiting for the data so we build
our own networking gear and our own
networking software why did we start
doing that a very simple answer we
couldn't buy for any price the scale and
performance network that we needed to
feed our processors was we had
particular applications that we needed
to run starting with web search but
continuing across many different kinds
of applications and today to Google
cloud we couldn't buy a network that
would provide the capabilities that we
needed no good
so you're the global lead for storage
services ok how is your design and the
services you provide different because
of what we have in our network well
building a global storage service is
first off card and in some ways and what
I mean
and the networking team brings the table
is they really take one of those really
difficult problems off of my deck of
things that I have to deal with so
oftentimes we're dealing with extremely
large data sets you know many many
petabytes and as a me mentioned we're
bringing that data together to sort of
answer questions and compute over and
being able to take the network out of
the equation because I can depend on it
to be there
I can depend on it to be really low
latency means that I can make a lot of
really interesting system design choices
so it means that you're not spending so
much time making sure the network is
delivering bandwidth you just assume
it's there you can design your services
for very very low latency just make that
assumption
you can make that assumption and it also
opens up a whole set of interesting
things that you can do I mean talked
about how we don't think about storage
is being local that means I can move
compute from one node to another very
quickly and access it with the same
latencies and this lets us work around
hotspots in the data or machines going
down and allows us to recover things
much faster good so how is our just I
know this is a huge question I'm asking
you to answer it
ad hoc like this but how is our approach
networking different from everybody
else's yeah that's a great question a
hard question I think it started with
scale and speed that that was the simple
part maybe 10 12 years ago but where
we're at right now is also availability
and what we call internally tail latency
so in other words when you're doing
distributed computation you don't just
care about how fast you can get at the
data most of the time excuse me in the
average case you care about what how
fast you can get at the data at the tail
end of the distribution of the nice
diversity is the worst case exactly so
we designed for availability we designed
for security and we designed for
predictability making sure that the
worst case is very close to the average
case not it so a very narrow bell curve
during you know distribution curve loop
and then actually becomes relatively
important if you take a computation
which starts and goes to one server and
then collects data from a thousand
different servers the probability that
you find that sort of tail latency and
impacting your computation is happens
all the time right so you have to really
plan for that worst case so in a
distributed operation you send it out to
many many servers it comes back in the
last one in yes is the one that actually
determines what we have to wait on all
the data to come back in order to
deliver a correct answer the design that
I've heard you talk about in some of
your in some of your talks is that we
have used all this commodity gear and
then centrally control it and use sort
of centralized dog rhythms to determine
what the actual connectivity of a
network is and so that's really
different right from the way
most people do it right that's right
what's beautiful about networking as the
traditionally defined is that no one
knows their role in the network everyone
sort of self discovers where they are
that's sort of the basis for the
internet one of many things that we saw
at Google though is that we're building
these data centers we're building these
data center networks and how we connect
all the server's together is
predetermined in other words the roles
and responsibilities of every switching
element is known at design time it's not
something that has to be discovered or
learned over time as is the case with
the traditional internet so at Google
again without really knowing it we
tripped upon the notion of Software
Defined Networking having a when was
this by the way this was about ten years
ago is when I started now the software
pi networking has very specific meanings
now and it talks about particular ways
of doing thing but the spirit in the end
is that you have a logically centralized
control over very large scale fabric and
that's what we wound up at and frankly
we borrowed these ideas from storage
systems at Google we always thought in
terms of course Android can say much
more about this that a storage
infrastructure consisting of tens of
thousands of disks is centrally
controlled so as naturally for us to
think the same way for how the network
was going to be planned and controlled
but I mean the argument that I've heard
and it don't know if it's a specious
argument or not but that having that
central control also creates a liability
and spawner ability it certainly can but
what we found is that it actually makes
the system simpler in the end compared
to a full the decentralized scheme you
do have the potential liability of a
centralized controller and that's why I
use the French word logically
centralized I don't literally have a
single key control it's just that we
have relatively sophisticated algorithms
based on systems like chubbie that we
published about in the past taxes base
leader election that make it easy for us
to build logically centralized control
so Google is running its own private
network connecting all of its data
centers and all of its services and if
you're a Google cloud platform customer
you're on that private
so is it different for you writing
services with the understanding that's a
private network rather than being you
know connected over the public Internet
yes why is it different I think in many
ways we're fairly spoiled right we have
you know a really strong team of
operations people that are monitoring
this network it is the same network that
carries our user facing traffic of
search Gmail and other things and so it
is a it's a resource that's incredibly
precious to us right we spend a lot of
time making sure that the capacity
planning is done well and that it
performs as sort of as the spec say the
bandwidth between our data centers is a
is a real enabler for us and frankly we
have more bandwidth between our data
centers and then many companies have
inside of their data centers and that
really breaks down distance where you
can think of data that is across the
data center as being almost local but
frankly we can also even think of data
that's stored in a different data center
that's something that we can go get as
part of our computation in many cases so
you have her customers talk about this
idea that they may be where were their
app is where their customers in the
world is just like the customer is right
there from a latency and a performance
and customer experience perspective
doesn't really matter where they're
running so I understand one of the
statistics has been thrown around is
that we have by sectional bandwidth we
need two points in our network at one
peda bit per second and I also know that
the total bandwidth aggregate bandwidth
of the entire internet right now is some
fraction of that like to tuturro bits
per second or something like that 200
200 terabytes or so there's an i-section
bandwidth roughly so how what's the
right way to think about those two
statistics it's kind of crazy that
Google has more bandwidth in its network
than the entire Internet does well so
this is the distinction between local
area networks and the Yui network so one
of our data center buildings will go to
scale to about a pet a bit per second
and that that allows all the server's
within that building in aggregate to
talk to one
had just enormous regulates so the way
to look at this is that you you can
transfer vast vast vast amounts of data
among all the servers to one another
what is this driven by its the fact that
computers can talk to each other much
faster than people can talk to the
network in other words what drives wide
area network communication across the
internet is people doing web searches
people consuming videos that actually
the amount of bandwidth required for
that in the grand scheme of things is
tiny compared to what the servers within
the data center need to do to provide
all that information to end-users ok so
when I type in a query big query to hit
a 3 terabyte table it comes back in a
few seconds it's because of that
bandwidth within that data center
there's thousands of servers that are
storing that data and if that we won we
wouldn't be able to fit any that they
don't any one server but even if they
could be grown on a computation power on
that server we have to distribute it
across thousands or so for it to work ok
so I understand we brought a switch from
our data center could go take a look at
it I'm so happy wow this thing is
enormous what is this this is one small
piece of a Jupiter Network this is what
powers all the connectivity in our data
center networks it is called a super
rack affectional way within the group
and it is one stage in a multi-stage
topology that connects all our servers
together so this is the middle stage
this connects all the servers server
racks to one another below it at the
first stage and above it is yet another
stage of networking that looks somewhat
like this basically data packets flow
from the server's up through the super
rack and then back down to other servers
across the network ok so what's
different here from what I might see in
another data center some of our
listeners may have experienced in their
data centers so when you buy commercial
gear you usually buy a single switch and
that might look a lot more glossy might
have a lot more shine on it it might not
have all of the cables that aren't
connecting things basically what we're
doing is we're exposing the fact that
any big switch
is composed of a lot of small ones so if
you were to zoom in here what you would
notice is that right over here is
actually one switch it's about seven
inches tall and there are eight of them
in this column another eight in here so
a total of sixteen switches in this
super rack each one of these switches is
a commodity switch so the things that
anyone might buy as a standard
top-of-rack switch the commodity and
they're driven by volume okay and so I
noticed that we've got yellow
fiber-optic cables here but also a lot
of conventional copper as well so how
are those how do those work together
what's the reason we had that so we have
some black cables these are the copper
cables again in traditional networks
which is what you would have is a copper
backplane it would be hidden would be in
the back it would have copper traces
edged on a piece of metal and that would
provide connectivity among all of the
individual switching elements here we've
chosen to expose that by using commodity
switches again commodity switches don't
have the big backplane so we actually
provide connectivity from every switch
to every other switch within the super
rack and those are the black copper
cables copper cables have a limited
reach about the reach of this super rack
here if you want to leave the super rack
distances beyond a few meters you need
to go fiber optics okay so these yellow
interconnects are the interconnects that
leave the super rack either going to the
higher stage of the switching topology
or down to the server racks
so for example a server racks would have
also the other end of these yellow fiber
optic cables that connect to the top
Iraq switch so how is this different
from earlier generations we actually
went along a number of different lines
in building our switching infrastructure
for modularity and the software and the
hardware is designed for being able to
support upgrade in place across the data
center and that was really a key insight
in that to be able to maintain
availability of our infrastructure we
had to live with upgrading and
continuously okay so the
the Google cloud platform that our
customers are on day is constantly being
upgraded and revised that's right this
is just one generation of our switching
gear one of many and what we found is
that both internally for Google products
from search to YouTube no one can really
tolerate taking down an entire data
center for six months while we upgrade
the entire infrastructure what that
means is that all of our servers must
continuously run while the network is
being upgraded from one generation to
the next and the super rack is a modular
piece right it is interchangeable with
other Super X such that we can be
upgrading one for another with it no
service down pack and so this is not the
be-all and end-all Google networking no
far from it so this was designed and
deployed in about 2012 it was the fifth
generation of in-house Google networking
here you can imagine that since 2012
we've been working on subsequent
generations some of which has seen
deployments in the data center now and
as we speak we're designing the next
next generation of hardware and software
that will go into the data center for
deployment in 2016 2017 and 2018 it's
never ending
to deliver the latest and greatest for
Google's Network so you can do a lot of
atoms in one place here for a software
guy right yes absolutely it's quite it's
quite professional looking great so
let's go talk more about the future
so that is quite a machine yeah some
switch yeah so what is that we're doing
there is unorthodox or controversial how
is how some of the designs we've put out
there influenced the industry well
that's a very interesting question I
think when we started down this path
many people thought that it just
couldn't work so commodity switches and
commodity switches delivering the right
levels of availability the right levels
of performance but you know we thought
it to inevitable in other words if you
look at the history of compute in the
history of storage it's followed similar
trends network has just gone down that
path most recently okay so how our
programming model how our apps going to
change programming models can you change
what does this mean further up the stack
for people that are creating software
yeah so so I mentioned earlier sort of
as a programmer as a system developer
being able to depend on the network to
get access to my data and you know I
think what we've seen historically is
you know steps to sort of disaggregate
compute from data itself and so this
started with creating disks that were
remote from where our servers were we've
been looking at disaggregating other
types of storage recently be a flash or
upcoming envy round and so what I think
you'll see going forward is this much
more of this programming model changes
around being able to ask other nodes or
other pieces of compute very quickly
over the network to retrieve data and
sort of bring it all together and so
from a programming point of view it'll
be as if your data is local no matter
where your compute happens to be Wow so
that's it's taking the program wherever
the data is on this it's taking the
program wherever the data is it also
allows us sort of coordinate more
effectively right so when you thinking
about large-scale distributed
computation you have a lot of trade-offs
you can make right you might find that
one server is slower than another reham
and you have the ability to go out and
ask people really quickly and answer
questions and sort of superfast networks
that you can depend on with low latency
frees you up to try some of these more
interesting techniques so the thing that
occurs to me is we're talking about this
is that this
same kind of disaggregation that you're
doing in the network space follows what
we did in the compute space as well and
that rather than think about the data
center as a collection of nodes we think
about it as one big computer and
networking and storage and even the
distributed services that run on our
infrastructure all kind of designed with
that same core idea in mind it's it's
the warehouse scale computer as the
paper says it really is the vision that
we're driving after is that the you can
think of the building as one unit of
compute one unit of storage and one
large switch that it connects all of
them together and Xander was mentioning
you need to think about where your data
is stored it's available to you always
as available to you really quickly and
the end convenient programming is being
able to just reference your data compute
on it generate the next piece of data
well when you think about the day in the
life of the average cloud computer cloud
developer today more than half the time
is spent just trying to make all this
stuff work right and if you take that
out of the equation
think about what amazing ask people can
write that's true you know we spend a
lot of time doing integration work so
bringing pieces of this things together
and at Google we've started to think a
lot about how programming models can
change to sort of work around these sort
of newfound latencies these new sort of
access route things and how that
actually changes how people develop
applications so what's next for your
teams what do you what should we expect
yeah it's a never-ending those set of
challenges so I think certainly on the
networking side of course the network's
are going to get faster they're going to
get lower latency I think that for us
one of the really interesting challenges
is how do we expose this all the way to
the Google cloud customer in other words
we have fairly specialized than powerful
programming primitives that we can deal
with networking environments how do we
securely and safely expose access to
basically if you will bare metal
performance all the way to the
virtualized customers productizing
advertising inside a Google how about
for you um you know we've been doing
storage at Google for a long time I'm
actually very very excited about sort of
our cloud customer workloads they bring
in new challenges for us and to give us
an opportunity to solve some some really
interesting problems you know mean
mentioned earlier that you know our
switches are developed and our networks
are developed years in advance right
it's it's a continually upgrade process
and so from a from a storage development
point of view we're already starting to
plan for what the next networks will
bring us what capabilities it will
actually unlock and so for us you know
we're starting to think about new tiers
of storage and how we integrate those
into applications and how they can
actually as a mean set impact cloud user
experiences how we can make development
simpler and how we can make reliability
availability and consistency of
operations around storage be better so
it's exciting times this is the right
time to working on Google cloud platform
so thank you both thank you all for
watching today and go out and try it